PEGI 18 how did we get here
technology is advancing at a phenomenal
rate artificial eyes - cybernetic limbs
the promise of a better future we now
have the choice to free ourselves from
any kind of limitation strength power
speed now a focus on were willing to
have these augmentations really been
interesting to say that what is
happening is unnatural
they were playing God but people were
scared of electricity and ro it won't be
without happens that this technology
falls into the wrong diseases or viruses
that could wipe out the human race
things are terrible witness were kind of
madness has gripped the mechanically
augmented people
this is an attack on humanity and the
universal values that we shape people
act by an occurrence is the appropriate
response and can we actually protect
ourselves from this happening again I
have no idea what happened I've never
shirks Q at what pliable governments
consider the idea of segregation for all
are saying we can be politically correct
or we can be foolish but it's going to
get worse than words Republic as its
voice to a growing list of countries
calling for the relocation of its ally
as it is no brief towards the severe
shortages of the drug neuropathy
required to inhibit the rejection of
augmentations
an anti orientation how many idiots you
get out there on the street
we will not relinquish our limbs do you
understand this happening on this planet
either
mainstream media toshing this meal the
officer suffered severe facial
you need to be afraid because they are
coming for you
you're a lot he makes a
corporations give the rise up
you see what you're kind of doing my
kind you sound just like them what God
is watching you
violence is completely out of control
is being picked for this corporate
politics what's their plan for us why
are they building concentration
going on out there
let there's even apples lot of people
died no you
we are freedom you will pay the moorings
in
I
looks like our rights coalition denies
responsible men
segregation Act has been
secur segregated districts I wanted to
take me we are still your neighbors your
brother's your sisters who loves
we lost everything
our dreams
our innocence were you taking over
were you taking on our humanity
you